Fashion is an evolving beast with the fashionistas
of the world endlessly attempting to create
impossibly fabulous and unique new outfits
for fashion shows.
A commonly seen element of such outfits is
that they’re often impractical, unwieldy
and, to the layperson, hilariously bizarre
looking.
So why don’t fashion shows just show off
clothes people might actually want to wear,
instead of going with outlandish outfits?
It turns out, although not as popular as runways
shows intended to show off the latest so called
“high fashion” pieces, Prêt-à-Porter
(literally, “ready-to-wear”) shows are
held every single year by most of the top
brands in fashion.
Said shows, meant to show off what’s going
to be “hot” next season, invariably feature
regular items of clothing and outfits mostly
identical to what we, the customer, will eventually
be able to buy in stores, or at least, some
version of them.
The fashion show pieces usually have a few
minor alterations made to accentuate a given
model’s figure, rather than being cut more
generically for the average consumer.
Although popular within the sphere of fashion,
these shows seldom receive the kind of high
profile coverage Haute Couture fashion gets
in the press- a fact that segues into one
of the key reasons fashion at these particular
shows is occasionally outlandish.
The truth is that most of the crazy outfits
you see have one real purpose- relatively
cheap advertising.
It turns out that creating a dress that looks
like it belongs in Lady Gaga’s closet and
featuring it prominently in a fashion show
is a relatively inexpensive way to get eyeballs
directed toward a particular designer’s
body of work, which of course is also akin
to why musicians like Lady Gaga frequently
pull the same stunt.
With regards to fashion shows, as Susannah
Frankel, one time fashion editor for The Independent,
states: “Although the more expensive shows
may cost upwards of £500,000, they still
work out cheaper than advertising campaigns
shot with big-name models and superstar photographers
and have a much more immediate and mainstream
audience.”
Wildly flamboyant or excessively fabulous
items of clothing are naturally going to pique
the interest of the press more and, as a result,
outfits seen at high fashion shows have been
getting progressively more ridiculous over
the years.
Think of it as a fashion arms race where the
goal is to make an impossibly chiselled model
doing their best to stay straight faced look
as silly as possible.
Looking beyond the consumer, these kind of
shows are also noted as functioning as a proving
ground of sorts for designers to show off
their skills via demonstrating the extremes
of what can be done with individual materials
and fabrics.
It should also be noted that while the clothes
seen on catwalks during high fashion shows
are generally never intended for sale, they
do often influence fashion in some way.
Said influences may be as subtle as the color
scheme shown off during a particular show
or the basic silhouette of clothing on display-
a popular example of the latter being skinny
jeans, which were widely mocked when first
seen on the catwalk before becoming the following
season’s “must have” item of clothing
and now relatively ubiquitous.
Of course, when using elements of a ridiculous
design, it is usually the case that designers
will greatly tone things down, drawing broadly
on ideas presented with the more garish outfits
worn by models to create something more palatable
to the general public.
A comparable practise in another industry
is that of so-called “Concept Cars” created
by car manufacturers.
Like high fashion, these cars are generally
designed more to both grab the press’s attention
and within the industry to showcase things
like a new manufacturing technique, material,
or feature, rather than the company actually
having any plans to manufacture and sell the
car shown.
But, again as with high fashion, elements
from these concept cars are occasionally integrated
into more toned down cars later available
for sale to the public.
Moving on to art side of things, it has been
argued that fashion, or more accurately high
fashion, should be considered a form of art,
with the most popular comparison between between
high fashion and modern art.
However, a notable critic of fashion being
considered a form of art is fashion designer
and billionaire Miuccia Prada, a woman often
called “She Who Must Be Obeyed” within
the industry.
For example, in an interview with New York
Magazine, Prada stated: “Art is for expressing
ideas and for expressing a vision.
My job is to sell.
And I like very much my job.”
But to conclude, the clothing at high fashion
shows looks garish and ridiculous for a number
of reasons, the most prominent among them
being to score some sweet column inches in
the news outlets of the world so as to also
bring more attention to a given designer or
brand’s less outlandish product.